normality as it was before will not come
back until we get a vaccine it haunts me
a little bit because you can't ever get
it just right
why am I not able to go back to the
issue for a lot of Canadians is that
they have no savings they live paycheck
to paycheck everyone stops going outside
their house and I should will slow
considerably problem is you can't
sustain that definitely it just makes
you feel like you're doing something to
help
[Music]
hello I'm Donna Friesen thanks for
joining us I know we're surrounded by
uncertainty that feels like everything
is changing there's a virus lurking
people are dying we have to stay
physically distant from the ones we love
and everyone wants to know is this the
new reality no one has the answer right
now but every week in this program we're
going to keep asking and we hope to
uplift you a bit to maybe even make you
laugh as we all find our way through
this leading the charge are the public
health officers Teresa Tam is the
federal officer in each province and
territory has their own they never seek
the limelight now though they are some
of the most famous and beloved leaders
in the country their daily briefings are
where canadians turn to get the facts
and learn about the science BC's public
health officer dr. Bonnie Henry is so
beloved she's inspired a fan club
t-shirts street art and musical tributes
she's also keenly aware that this virus
came out of nowhere and that makes it
very hard to predict where it's going
dr. Henry I know you are so incredibly
busy thank you for taking the time to
talk to us you know I want to start by
asking when we watched what happened in
China and saw what this virus is capable
of back in January how it overwhelmed
the hospitals that it killed even health
care workers entire cities were put
under lockdown did you think what was
happening there could happen here do you
have a forgive me but a kind of holy
crap moment absolutely and I think you
know when talking about it with with my
colleagues to the media to the public at
the time we were holding out hope that
China would be able to contain this but
it became apparent not long after I mean
I knew we would undoubtedly have cases
in in Canada and in BC just given the
travel patterns that we new around the
world I don't think I was prepared for
how severe it was going to be in other
countries particularly when it hit
Europe and many of us I think around
world when we saw what was happening in
Italy was really shocking these were all
the things that we had talked about in
preparing for pandemics for a long time
but I never really thought that I would
actually have to do them but I think you
know here in Canada we we had the luxury
of time to prepare us and to help us
understand what things need it to be
done you have so much experience with
the SARS outbreak in Toronto where you
helped lead the response and the Ebola
outbreak in Uganda those were life and
death challenges - how does what you're
doing now compared to that you know I
think every pandemic is different every
outbreak is different all of them have
their challenges this one certainly is
unprecedented in the impacts that it's
had around the world and you know as you
say I've been involved with many very
serious very tragic outbreaks and this
one just the the whole societal impacts
of it have been immense you have such a
fine balance to keep as a public health
officer informing people but not
panicking people deciding when an asked
becomes an order it's critical that you
keep the public on your side throughout
this how much does that weigh on you a
lot of it weighs on me it weighs on me
you know we want to put in enough
restrictions to do what we need to do to
contain this virus right now we know
there's there's no treatment there's no
prevention if you've been exposed we
just need to make sure that we can care
for you appropriately and that we do
everything we can so you don't pass it
on to somebody else
but every single measure that we take
that unintended consequences the numbers
of people who have had their lives
disrupted whether it's from kovat 19 and
the tragedies in our long-term care
homes or whether it's people who have
had their surgeries canceled or people
who are unemployed because of the the
huge economic fallout I think that you
know the everything about this has been
so challenging and
that the sort of balance of trying to
get just enough restriction to do what
we need to do but not too much and it it
haunts me a little bit because you can't
ever get it just right though there is
widespread transmission in some areas of
the world we are not in that position
yet I know you are a doctor dr. Henry
not a TV personality your briefings have
happened almost every day though for 12
weeks now you've become must-see TV and
British Columbia people are drawing
pictures of you and murals of you I'm
sure they're sending you things and
they're writing songs about you that's a
barbershop quartets in the NEEMO they
love you it's pretty it's pretty
remarkable isn't it can you see me blush
[Music]
amazing voices I guess what I'm asking
is what do you think it says about how
the public is looking to people like you
to public health officers and to experts
and to science to lead us out of this
well I am heartened that people are
looking to experts into science
particularly in Canada and you know I've
said this many times what I do is I'm
the face and sometimes the voice of a
lot of people and a lot of people who
are very committed and passionate and
doing the work on the ground and we are
a team and we are a team across the
country we know each other well we talk
all the time sometimes daily these days
but it is a privilege and very humbling
for me to represent the work that so
many people are doing to try and keep us
safe in our communities across this
country the million-dollar question is
when this will end now I know there's no
precise answer to that I'm not going to
ask you that but what about an exit
strategy a plan for a ladder if you like
that we can start climbing to get out of
this you must be working on that
absolutely and in those same way that we
were watching China we were watching
Italy we're watching Singapore Hong Kong
Germany we're now watching them and
seeing where you know in some ways again
we have the luxury of everybody else
going before us right now of course we
are still very much in the middle of
things in the United States and across
Canada but we are seeing what measures
others are doing and how it works so
clearly watching Wuhan very closely
where they've just real if to
restrictions quite a lot and we have the
luxury of some modeling we have some
really brilliant minds that have been
looking at this looking at what we might
think of over time and yes we are
planning from the very first day we put
the first measures in place my goal my
aim in our direction to people was all
right what do we need to know that we're
in a place where we can stop doing some
of these things I think the reality is
that some things are going to change for
a long time maybe 18 months maybe years
things around distancing things around
cleaning our hands regularly the things
that do protect us that that safe
distance between us until we have a herd
immunity or community immunity whether
that's because people have been infected
or hopefully because we have a vaccine
that prevents us from getting sick with
this virus we're going to have to do
some things for quite some time when is
it time dr. Henry to tell the public
what that strategy is how it will work
when some of the restrictions can be
lifted and how that will happen none of
us are in the place right now where we
can consider how we're going to lift
restrictions that doesn't mean we we
aren't thinking about it and we need to
think about it but we need to be
realistic about the fact that we have a
few more weeks before we can start
actually implementing these things and
we'll talk more about what that looks
like in the near future but right now it
has to be done in a very thoughtful way
and a very a way that makes sure that we
have those surveillance pieces in place
so we know if we're starting to get more
cases again that might lead to outbreaks
and overwhelm our health system so it's
going to be a fine balance for a while
you know we sometimes talk about the
cases in the deaths as if they are
statistics they are of course and we all
know their individual people you are
making life-and-death decisions there
must be times when there really hits you
absolutely and you know it's the thing
that keeps me up a week at night more
than anything is you know have we missed
things what have we done enough in this
area or that area you know that the
tragedies of you know recently we've had
people who've died from this at home
what can we do differently how can we
support people and the other part of it
that's so important is these measures
these unprecedented measures we've put
in place across the world you know the
impact on children the impact on people
who can't who haven't been able to get
their their surgery that they need it's
been a it's it's very challenging to to
reconcile all of those and of course
everybody who who dies from this who's
affected by this their family their
caregivers their community but I also
think you know that's what that is why
people are willing and able and are
doing what we've asked them to do around
social distancing around keeping their
in keeping that safe distance for people
staying close to their family working
from home because we know that if we get
sick with this it is our loved ones our
family in our close community that we're
going to pass it to so all of us are in
this together and I I think you know if
that's the impetus so many of us have to
make sure we're doing the right things
coming up from family gatherings to
playdates answers to the questions our
kids are asking and we certainly are
coping I think we've created a lot of
capacity how frontline workers are
taking care of Kovac patients and
themselves and Canada's done pretty well
we could have done better what we've
learned so far and the new tests that
could get some of us back to work
[Music]
one of the things this virus has shown
us is that there are limits to our
medical and scientific knowledge the
novel coronavirus is moving faster than
the world's best scientists in Canada
and around the world they are toiling
away in labs doing the painstaking work
of creating a vaccine and working to
ramp up testing to find out who is
infected and who might be immune never
has the world been so focused on testing
and never has there been so much
attention on the people who develop
administer and analyze those tests
Canada's done done pretty well we could
have done better I would have liked to
have seen more testing early on to get a
better sense of where we were there's no
doubt that early testing and contact
tracing finding those original cases can
have a big impact on the eventual spread
because you're stopping it from
spreading early on dr. Michael Gartin
was one of the leading figures in the
fight against SARS in 2003 oh yeah I was
very different I mean in SARS the
technology wasn't nearly as advanced
right so we weren't testing the general
public at all for SARS we were only
testing people in hospitals who had who
had compatible symptoms and even then we
weren't doing it until the second half
because we didn't even know what SARS
was for the first half so this has been
very different there was no there was no
community testing at all for SARS when
those on the frontlines talk about the
importance of testing they're actually
talking about different tests all of
which could be key to reopening the
world the first is the antigen test
processed methodically in a lab it tells
us who is infected right now and could
pass it on to others the antigen test
involves poking a long swab deep into
the nose - just above the nasopharynx
and rotating it the goal is to collect
microscopic material it's recently been
in the lungs which is where the virus is
believed to replicate the swab goes into
a vial and is sent to a lab we know
there still aren't enough test kits or
labs to test every one that's really
gonna be one of our main strategies to
get us out of the mess we're in right
now which is if you can have easy access
to a test even if you've got mild
symptoms if you're positive then we know
to tell you to go home and isolate for
14 days and we can
also tell your contacts to be wary for
symptoms if we can do all that then were
much more like what South Korea has done
from the very beginning which is a lot
of testing and really doing a lot of
contact tracing and they've been able to
keep a lid on this pretty much better
than almost any other country there are
more rapid tests on the way Health
Canada is analyzing a portable rapid
test made by Spartan bioscience it uses
a throat swab and in a device about the
size of a coffee cup it's said to
deliver results in minutes in the US the
FDA has approved a rapid test - made by
Abbott Laboratories it also claims to
deliver results in minutes it's being
used by the White House but there are
concerns about accuracy and scaling it
up for wider use in addition to
diagnosing patients there's another kind
of test that's being developed and
scrutinized in Canada this one is a
blood test for antibodies which reveals
whether you've had the virus in the past
possibly without symptoms and are now
potentially immune Health Canada plans
to test it first in health care workers
and select populations once approved it
could allow you to safely return to work
and the more people that are in that
category the more the economic engine
can start revenue gained so I think I do
see this as sort of the light at the end
of the tunnel which has been used by
many people in terms of how to be
actually forge a path back to what life
used to be Jim would get is director of
research at Mount Sinai Hospital in
Toronto the team there is developing a
new and faster blood test to detect
antibodies and the important thing is to
try to identify as people have the virus
and recover from it a lot of people
actually don't even know or they have
very mild symptoms and so they've
they've they're actually immunized
against the virus but and it's a big but
it is not yet 100 percent certain people
with antibodies will be immune or how
long immunity would last the virus could
mutate so the optimism is an educated
guess right now
dr. Craig Jenny is an epidemiologist at
the University of Calgary
he says the antibody test could help in
the development of a vaccine but the
reality is a vaccine could still be a
year to 18 months or longer away until
then we could be confined to our bubbles
physical distancing remains the most
effective way to slow the spread it's
possible the virus could in several
months be contained enough to start
relaxing some restrictions on our lives
for now the restaurants theaters malls
and countless businesses will stay dark
as we wait for the doctors researchers
scientists and public health experts to
lead us back into the light with me now
is dr. Taz leme nimshi she's director of
medical innovation at Humber River
Hospital in Toronto dr. NIMH G thank you
so much for all you do and for joining
us you've been treating patients with
Kovac 19:00 you're on the front lines of
this we've heard Canadian hospitals are
still coping have not been overwhelmed
what's it been like for you I think
that's fair to say we we certainly are
coping I think we've created a lot of
capacity in the system that's that's
helped us certainly in terms of dealing
with the traffic now coming into the
system and in addition I think certainly
we can see when we're looking at our
numbers and doing our modeling the
efforts that we have in the community
are really helping and that's in terms
of folks social distancing and not being
out and about is making a big difference
and of course we say that not to suggest
that it's made a difference it continues
to make a difference and so it's it's
crucial that we continue to do those
things yes can't repeat that message
enough in Ontario right now it looks
like about half of people who have been
hospitalized end up in intensive care
can you give us a sense of how you
assess who
to move into intensive care what their
symptoms are at what point to that you
you put them on a ventilator just for
those of us who aren't in that setting
sure so when people are coming into
hospital the main symptom that they're
expressing is really shortness of breath
that's what drives people to leave their
homes for the most part and come into
the hospital looking for care and so
when we're trying to determine what
these people need in terms of hospital
care if someone requires oxygen that's
given through many different delivery
mechanisms so if you require
supplemental oxygen through tube that's
in your nose or a mask that's covering
your face you might be able to just
manage then on an inpatient bed so
beyond a ward in the hospital but if
you're requiring higher and higher
levels of oxygen so that those delivery
mechanisms are no longer going to work
for you that's when we look at putting
you on what we call a ventilator or a
breathing machine and when that really
entails is sedating somebody completely
and then putting a tube we call an ET
tube down that person's throat into
their trachea or their breathing tube
where they're windpipe and then
attaching them to a machine that's doing
that breathing for them and allowing us
to give higher levels of oxygen to that
individual doctor named G what concerns
you worries you most about this virus
you know there's there's a whole host of
things we're looking at this is novel so
we don't have immunity in our
communities which is why so many of us
are getting sick so quickly there's
still a lot that we don't understand
about why some people get sicker than
others there's the things that we do
know for example the comorbidities that
you've heard about people with
pre-existing health conditions but there
are young people that are getting sicker
than others so so why do some people
have milder illness than others
certainly there's a lot of anxiety and
worry about lack of other treatments
this being so novel and then not having
a vaccine and so the big question is how
do you safely start decreasing some of
the measures that the tightness on the
measures that we have in the community
to allow some of that normalcy to come
back as the weeks and months progress
and how are we going to know that we're
doing that safely so we're not putting
ourselves again at risk of
second surge as we call it coming up the
issue for a lot of Canadians is that
they have no savings coming to grips
with our new financial reality and
helping our kids understand why life
isn't the same
[Music]
we know so many of you are struggling
financially staying home
sounds like a luxury but it is not if
you have lost your job and can't pay the
bills or the rent or the mortgage there
is some government help on the way and
lots of people will qualify for it but
the fact is before this virus ever
arrived many Canadians were living well
beyond their means and now as david
aiken explains it's crunch time
canada has hardly ever been a nation of
savers canada is a nation of spending
and the choice by canadians to be
spenders not savers has left millions of
Canadian households anxious and
vulnerable in this once in a generation
crisis for most of the last decade we
have been spending what we earned new
TVs new cars new homes and if our
earnings were not enough we borrowed and
why not
interest rates have been stuck in
generational lows job growth had been
strong so strong that unemployment also
touched generational lows the Cova 19
crisis heard all of that upside down and
the issue for a lot of Canadians is that
they have no savings they live paycheck
to paycheck they might have a bit of
money in the account that will get them
to the end of the month but if they're
off work for a month or two they're in
serious financial difficulty and that
has put into stark relief another number
that has hovered near generational loans
the national household savings rate for
the last decade Canadians have barely
saved 3 and a half cents of every dollar
of disposable income 3 and a half cents
to the dollar there's always something
that I need to pay for from my business
and supplies to order or an event like a
market to pay for making roses
self-employed and artisan she supplies
boutiques and gift stores across Canada
with what she makes and her business has
dried up so I've never been able to save
money with my business I also have a
mortgage too so just the high cost of
running a business and the cost of
living has never
allow me to save any money indeed almost
one in every three Canadians or 31% say
they have less than a week of savings or
no savings at all to rely on that's
according to a poll by Ipsos provided
exclusively to global news just under
one in four or 23% say they have two to
four weeks of savings while another one
in five or twenty percent say they have
between five and thirteen weeks of
savings to draw on that partly explains
why the federal government focus has
been on replacing income rather than
protecting savings don't have any
savings I do have a good line of credit
and credit cards so I could go for
probably several months using that but
it's not really a sustainable income was
all most Canadians had most of the folks
that are gonna be laid off are not
making $100,000 a year $150,000 a year
and have a big savings account most of
them are making 12 14 $15 an hour
they have no savings how they live
paycheck to paycheck and ironically
Canada may not now be able to afford to
become a nation of savers to speed and
strengthen any economic recovery Canada
will have to spend spend on a meal out
at a local restaurant spend on new
clothes from a favorite retailer spend
on a new home and all its furnishings
that's how Canadians will bring back the
economy and put neighbors back to work
by spending not saving you can see them
in every Canadian neighborhood kids with
their noses up against the glass peering
out at a world they no longer understand
wondering what happened to their lives
parks and playgrounds are closed the
news is all about frightening stories of
a mysterious virus and all the sick and
dying people and as Jeff sample explains
children have lots and lots of questions
like a lot of kids Breanna and Bryson
have been stuck at home for weeks
finding creative ways to pass the time
we've been hanging rocks we got some
right here that's cool
hold him up let me see those look great
how does it feel being at home for so
long they're growing bored and a bit
worried about this virus everyone's
talking about child psychologists say
that's important global News asked kids
to send us their Topco vid 19 questions
Bryson wanted to know about his grandma
my question was why can't I have my
grandma so we put his question and
others to the experts you might be
passing on the virus to her and we know
that people especially brown ones and
grandpas usually get a lot sicker than
maybe young people do in fact most young
people who've gotten the virus have done
a great job fighting it
how did Coby maintains that experts
aren't actually sure but they think the
virus started in a bat in China
occasionally the viruses can pass from a
bat to another animal perhaps through a
bite or some secretions from the nose of
the bat and then sometimes that animal
another planet and this covert 19 on the
hairbrush it's certainly possible if you
were to copy to your head and then touch
your hairbrush
the virus could pass from your hands to
the hairbrush as for other planets
experts don't think kovat 19 could
survive in space but some corona viruses
can live in freezing temperatures for up
to two years kovat night teens germs can
survive on some surfaces like a plastic
boy for up to three days the virus
doesn't jump so it doesn't go from a toy
into your nose the only way you can get
those if you touch it and then touch
your mouth and nose what's your name
Foster how many minutes are we gonna be
holy how long till I go to our friends
house and grandma's house again
unfortunately experts say it's not a
matter of minutes but weeks I do think
that these physical distancing measures
are going to last for at least another
six to eight weeks if not longer
but then if everyone does their part
Bryson and his sister will get to visit
grandma again very soon
coming up a glimpse into our new reality
normality will not come back until we
get a vaccine for this and more
sustainable future I'm hoping that this
is a bit of a wake-up call rethinking
the way we work and socialize if someone
had said to you in December that by
April millions of people all over the
world would be infected with a
mysterious new virus that has no vaccine
you'd think they were talking about a
Hollywood script it's happened so fast
it almost doesn't seem real and it has
everyone asking when will it end
Jackson prosecco went looking for
answers this is not normal at least it
wasn't until a few weeks ago when
everything we take for granted
everything moved just beyond our grasp
six weeks ago
nobody worried about touching their own
face or leaving their own house nobody
thought about lining up to buy groceries
now there are more planes on the ground
than in the sky work has become a luxury
for those who still have a job
especially for those who can work from
home and home is where most of us now
spend our time sitting and wondering how
we get back to the world we knew we know
that the mass social distancing measures
will will work they will bring cases
down we've seen that everywhere they've
been tried and it stands to reason that
if everyone stops going outside their
house that case transmission will slow
considerably the problem is you can't
sustain that indefinitely Jeremy Coonan
Dyke is an expert in pandemic
preparedness at the Center for global
development in Washington DC he like
virtually every expert has bad news for
anyone who thinks there's an easy road
back you need a plan B phase two you
have to pass the baton to a different
set of protective measures so that you
can keep cases low while actually having
a functional economy again and allowing
people to move again you governments
have such a plan they're still dealing
with an unfolding health disaster and a
mysterious new virus
Koby at 19 is stealthy and it's lethal
no one appears to have natural immunity
no one knows how widespread infections
really are or if the virus will come and
go with the seasons the 1918 flu
pandemic went on till 1920 so this could
easily go on a couple of years waxing
and waning and dr. Peter Hotez is a
vaccine scientist at Baylor College of
Medicine in Houston he believes
government's need a strategy for how
daily life will operate for the next two
years yes two years that's the length of
time it could take to develop tests and
distribute a vaccine once the surge in
cases is over do you see us potentially
getting to a place where restrictions
and social distancing are loosened and
then tightened up as localized outbreaks
pop up yeah that's that's a possible
scenario but how do you operationalize
that and and and how do you inform
companies or universities when to stay
open went too close and how do you get
people to feel comfortable doing that
who might be terrified about resuming
normal daily activity so a lot of
complexities without a lot of precedent
the complexity is not lost on public
officials anywhere they've struggled to
explain what a way out might look like
if back to normal means acting like
there never was a coronavirus problem I
don't think that's gonna happen until we
do have a situation where you can
completely protect the population I
think even after we're through this
first wave we will need to remain
vigilant and we will need to bring in
different measures normality as it was
before will not come back full on until
we get a vaccine for this
in South Korea they've learned that
social distancing is only half the
battle
the government implemented an aggressive
system of testing contact tracing public
alerts and quarantine to keep case
numbers and fatalities relatively low
even then life is nowhere close to
returning to what it once was
the virus keeps popping up other
countries have begun to relax
restrictions only to experience a second
wave of infection Canada the US and
Europe are still at step 1 trying to
contain the outbreak and public health
officials say they're nowhere close to
being ready to think about anything else
how are we going to get back to normal
without higher levels of testing if
people are walking around with this
virus that they don't even know it right
now our focus is to tackle this actual
outbreak at some point in the near
future we will be looking at how do we
apply serologic testing for example to
look at the level of immunity in the
population even though everything shut
down all at once it may come back slowly
in waves once the peak of cases is over
perhaps restaurants and bars reopen with
fewer seats inside schools could come
next big concerts and sporting events
are likely a long way off dr. ali mock
dodd worked to develop the pandemic
models used by the white house so until
we have a vaccine our definition of
normal
should be totally different what normal
is so I don't expect all of us to be
back to normal
that's 100% immediately but in a staged
approach to make sure the virus is not
circulating and we don't allow this
virus to have a second wave the risk is
in coming back too fast there's little
room for trial and error when human
lives are on the line dr. Lena when is
the former public health commissioner
for the city of Baltimore I don't think
that you can lift it overall all
together and say let's go back to
exactly what our Priya komen 19 days
were like that's not going to work
because we know what the consequence is
going to be we're going to have a huge
number of deaths and Koba 19 will spiral
out of control
almost every expert agrees a vaccine is
the fastest safest way to get our world
back even if it means a year or more of
waiting until that happens we're stuck
in a cat and mouse game with something
that can't be seen or detected until
it's too late it may be the most painful
weight of our lives so we're in this for
a while we are and it is a new normal
that we all have to get used to
recognizing how difficult this is and
how many sacrifices are going to be
borne by everyone but if we stop down
then these sacrifices will be in vain
and it will take much longer and many
more lives will be lost all this virus
needs is a human body it doesn't care if
it's a prime minister or a sanitation
worker but some in our society are at
much greater risk than others those who
don't have the luxury of working from
home for example or live in confined
spaces and can't physically distance
themselves from others
chi-chan has been thinking about how our
society might be altered when we get
through all of this he's a professor at
the Institute for resources environment
and sustainability at the University of
British Columbia with a background in
science policy and ethics kai thanks for
joining us you know a lot of people have
talked about rethinking who is an
essential worker and the value we place
on jobs that now we know are such
lifelines for us like cleaners and
grocery and agricultural workers
delivery drivers what's your thought on
that it's really clear who matters most
in these times it's also clear that a
whole bunch of folks in our society are
fundamentally dependent on working all
the time right like week to week and
it's a real problem that these kinds of
interruptions to the daily lives mean
that people can't pay rent etc and I
think we need to structure our society
in order to enable these kinds of events
not to disrupt the whole economy in
people's lives you know how has the
public health measures in place the
lockdowns the physical distancing
you rethink how we live both in our work
culture and our social culture a lot of
people are anxious to get back to
business as usual and for me I'm hoping
that this is a bit of a wake-up call
that we're not going back to how things
used to be but rather moving forward
bouncing forward into a better future
one good example of that is the way that
we work remotely with colleagues I have
a whole bunch of international meetings
that I'm supposed to go to and due to
the coronavirus we've been having to
have those meetings online we're working
through the really challenging aspects
they're trying to maintain that kind of
social nuance that we have in
face-to-face dealings through online
media it's not perfect yet but hopefully
we'll be able to bring in new
technologies in order to make that work
well for all of us but it is hard to
imagine right now getting on a packed
airplane going to big international
conferences surrounded by people do you
think we will actually rethink how
business gets done or we're social
beings will we just revert to the way
things were I actually think we will we
you know at least in my community in the
environment and sustainability space
it's been clear for a long time that we
need to start to rethink these things
for climate reasons and for other
environmental reasons and we've just
been kind of slow on just waiting for
you know the right push well arguably
this is a really good push that forced
us to work through the difficult bits so
then it starts to become normal which it
surely will before this thing is over
which unfortunately it's gonna drag on
you know okay we are social beings and
maybe business can change how you know
it does business but what about the
connectedness between people we love I
mean so much of that is shut off right
now that's not something that's just
sustainable for humans is it no no I
mean not the interpersonal day-to-day
you know it's it isn't quite the same at
least doesn't feel that way yet to talk
to people at a distance of two meters or
more and you know maybe we will get
somewhat used to that I don't know I'm
not probably not in the short term but I
certainly do hope that we can go back to
being able to you know hug
our friends and shake hands again yeah
it's gonna be such a long time though
before that that happens that you know I
think we will start to rethink pretty
big decisions like how far we are from
family for example you know I but it's
it's really paying me to see that my
parents struggling through this time and
having my sister to rely upon but me not
being able to help over there in Toronto
coming up the new reality of the party
[Music]
how quarantine is bringing out the
creativity of Canadians there's so much
information surrounding coronavirus out
there now we know you have questions
email your questions at global news GaN
CA tune in to global national or go to
global news CA / Kawano virus now to
find the answers
while many of us are stuck at home what
one thing is keeping a lot of people
busier than ever social media for some
people it's been a way to keep in touch
with friends and family for others it's
an outlet if you haven't been impressed
with the creativity coming out of
self-isolation
well as they say you haven't been
watching our Mike Armstrong has
now we've all had phones with cameras up
there at the top for a while now and
somehow we still film vertically but
there's something we haven't had until
now and that's a ton of time on her
hands I have a friend for example
sharing pictures of his different
sneakers it's a little strange but that
same friend flagged this family having
fun I'm not sure how much skill went
into making this video but it's
basically impossible to watch without
smiling smiles are kind of the one
infectious thing that's okay right now
[Music]
now that video is one of thousands on a
Facebook page called
ultimate online Nova Scotia kitchen
party kovat 19 edition
[Music]
the group started just two weeks ago and
is ballooned up to include contributions
from every corner of Canada and close to
a hundred other countries
well welcome from sunny South Korea
jörgen eyes or says there are a lot of
people looking to avoid cabin fever or
as she calls it Shack wacky I kind of
like it we have many different types of
talent we've got people who are
literally just picking up instruments
for the first time people who are
dusting off their old instruments and
we've even got some professionals in the
group which is pretty cool to see there
are a lot of parodies out there right
now Disney's a big inspiration hard to
believe this isn't the original
you know theories Halloween from snakes
and Bette speaking there are some new
takes on some old classics and there is
no way I was leaving the Barenaked
Ladies out of this now some have taken
the inspiration of this infection and
created the sort of music that gets into
your head and refuses to leave
[Music]
if it's a Canadian toe-tapper year after
they're out there how about the Prime
Minister on wearing masks prevent you
from speaking
[Music]
and I don't know if banjos and auto-tune
have ever been used together before but
it works for Alberta's premier talking
about hoarders there must be a special
place in hell a special place in hell
special place and calm Blanc that
sticking with Alberta the orchestras in
Calgary and Edmonton set aside their
hockey rivalry and recorded on their
phones a very familiar tune
unfortunately it really makes me miss
hockey some of us don't find it quite as
easy as this Ontario family to occupy
our time they recreated the entire
Simpsons opening maybe skill is an
absolutely essential when it comes to
spreading smiles it helps if you can
hold a tune or know a specific dance but
you can be contagious in a positive way
[Music]
just by being positive
[Music]
one person who has lived through
countless ups and downs and always
endured is queen elizabeth ii herrera
broadcast to the nation and the world
recently was watched by millions she
talked about strength and patience and
kindness until better days return we
will be with our friends again we will
be with our families again we will meet
again that's a reference to a song by
virile in familiar to a young Princess
Elizabeth and millions in the
Commonwealth during the Second World War
an old song that has new meaning today
i'm donna freezin we'll be back in seven
days for now good night
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]